another police shooting of an unarmed
black man in minneapolis spurs riot and
rashida talib calls for an end to
policing i'm ben shapiro this is the ben
shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressivevpn you have a right to
privacy defend your rights at
expressvpn.com
slash bet i'll get to all the news in
just one moment first do you actually
think that the nation's economy is going
to be insulated
from joe biden's massive tax increases
those are coming how about from
inflation
that will come sometime in the near
future because you can't blow money into
the economy this way
and hope that it's not going to create
some sort of bubble well there is a
great way to protect your savings do it
over 10 000 other smart investors have
done
convert a portion of your retirement
accounts into gold and silver with my
friends over at birch gold when
inflation hits
gold and silver are in fact your safe
haven and birch gold group those are the
people i trust to help you convert an
ira or eligible 401k
into an ira backed by gold and silver
through april 30th on qualifying
purchases when you open a precious
metals ira with birch gold they'll send
you
a free home safe birch gold those are
the people i buy my gold from you can
trust them as well text ben
247 4747 for your free information kit
on
precious metals iras or speak with a
birch gold representative today with 10
000 customers they have an eight plus
rating with the better
business bureau countless five star
reviews they can help you too text ben
to 47 47 47 for your free safe with
qualifying purchase and to get started
talk to my friends over at birch gold
ask all your questions and then take at
least a little bit
of your savings and put it into gold to
insulate against the possibility of
failure in the united states
economy alrighty so the news at this
hour
continues to be widespread unrest
in the city of minneapolis all following
the shooting of dante wright
dante wright was pulled over on the
basis of
a of a traffic violation and then
he died basically because it seems that
the cop in this particular incident
drew a taser this female cop she drew a
taser as opposed to her gun
mistook her taser for the gun and
proceeded to shoot the
the 20 year old dante wright this
is very reminiscent of the situation
back in 2015
in which a black man in oakland named
oscar grant was shot by a police officer
who claimed that he thought he was
firing a taser
at oscar grant and in fact shot a gun at
him and killed him
uh dante right it seems like the same
sort of thing and this seems like a
pretty open and shut case of involuntary
manslaughter
the reason i say that is because there's
body cam footage and it is obvious from
the body cam footage that the cop in
this particular case
was not intending to kill dante wright
and
pretty much obviously says on the tape
whoops which is you know awful and
horrible
also it is manslaughter not murder here
is here's what that body cam
footage sounded like
so wright is being handcuffed in this
particular tape
and uh they go to uh handcuff right and
then wright tries to break free tries to
get in the car
is resisting arrest but the punishment
for resisting arrest is not being shot
obviously the officer withdraws gun
and proceeds too
okay and you can hear the cop there
shout taser taser taser
right she says taser taser tastes she
obviously thought that she was firing a
taser at dante right it was not in fact
a taser it was a gun
and there's been this attempt by the
twitterverse to try and say
that she clearly knew it was a gun but
she script that's not right i mean it's
pretty obvious that she
thought she was firing a taser that does
not justify the activity nor does it
mean that you get off
in terms of criminal liability scot-free
the officer in the oscar grand case
ended up being convicted of manslaughter
and doing some jail time
this all resulted in the usual round of
rioting and looting in minneapolis
the brooklyn center police chief came
out and said right off the top
this gunshot was in fact accidental here
was the bro
here's the brooklyn center police
chief's name is tim gannon talking about
this
as i watch the video and listen to the
officers commands it is my belief that
the officer
had the intention to deploy their taser
but instead shot mr right
with a single bullet
this appears to me from what i viewed
and the officer's reaction in distress
immediately after
that this was an accidental discharge
that resulted in the tragic death
of mr right okay well the the chief tim
gannon
was then really sort of berated by
members of the media and he says listen
i'm just trying to be honest here
i'm trying to be transparent with you
this is what i'm here for
okay i'm the leader of this department
they expect me to lead create a safe
city
that's what i'm trying to do so that's
that's it
i hope you're not trying to okay and uh
yeah i'm emotional guys he's being
honest i'm just trying to be honest
okay well being honest is not something
that uh apparently the media celebrate
in this day and age when it comes to
dealing
with these sorts of very fraught
situations obviously a tragedy
like this one how much is honesty not
prized well here's an example
there is a brooklyn city manager his
name is kurt bogany
and he was giving a press conference and
he was asked if this officer is going to
be summarily fired
and corporal gainey said what is true
legally speaking he said the officer is
entitled to due process we have union
rules
and once due process is carried forward
then we'll tell you more hey here's what
bogany had to say all employees working
for the city of brooklyn center are
entitled to due process
with respect to discipline this employee
will receive due process and that's
really
all that i can say today okay this
resulted
i kid you not and kurt bulgani being
fired according to fox news
kurt bulgani was fired on monday evening
hours after he publicly disagreed with
mayor mike elliot's assertion that the
police officer who fatally shot a black
man
in a minneapolis suburb should be
immediately fired in response to the
incident
mayor mike elliott said effective
immediately our city manager has been
relieved of his duties
and the deputy city manager will be
assumed assuming his duties moving
forward i'll continue to work my hardest
to ensure good leadership at all levels
of our city government because good
leadership obviously means that you
don't call for due process for people
who are going to end up in the criminal
justice system
good leadership means that people are
summarily fired without due process
obviously
i mean not just a merely fired but if
you say that they should have due
process
then you lose your job too okay this is
pretty wild stuff and frankly
i think there's probably a first
amendment case here on behalf of the
brooklyn city manager i mean if you're
getting fired by a public agency
for the great crime of saying that
somebody needs due process before you
fire them
i i don't know how that's a fireable
offense this person has a pretty obvious
claim
against the the city for for the firing
eliot said let me be very clear my
position is we can't afford to make
mistakes that lead to the loss of life
of other people in our profession i do
fully support releasing the officer
of his or her duties before leaving the
podium elliott noted bulgania city
manager had the authority to determine
whether the officer would be fired
and bogeny said that this employee will
receive due process that's all i can
really
say and then when asked about personal
feelings bogeny again said
due process said if i were to answer
that question i'd be contradicting what
i said a moment ago which is to say that
all employees are entitled to due
process
and after that due process discipline
will be determined if i were to say
anything else
i'd be contradicting the idea of due
process the mayor didn't like this
and the mayor one of the reasons the
mayor didn't like this is because the
mayor and the city council
are afraid that if this person is not
summarily fired without due process
and by the way this will end with the
person being fired it's a pretty obvious
breach of of duty on the behalf on the
part of the officer and a criminal act
in all likelihood this person probably
goes to jail for involuntary
manslaughter council member chris
lawrence anderson
said she voted to fire bogeny out of
fear of potential reprisals from
protesters if she did not
so we are now having our government run
by mob rule
we are now having the mob determine
whether people are guilty or innocent
and what punishments they should receive
and whether or not you are allowed to
say that somebody should receive due
process or not
and meanwhile you have rashida talib a
congresswoman from minnesota
from michigan saying this wasn't an
accident at all
and which of course is patently crazy
here's where she did it to lieb's tweet
quote it wasn't an accident
policing in our country is inherently
unintentionally racist
oh is it inherently and intentionally
racist because it seems to me that when
you watch that tape
it is extremely obvious that this was an
accident
the the female officer in question
shouts taser taser taser
fires a gun and then says oh my god i
shot him
it's hard to see a more open and shut
case of involuntary manslaughter than
that
it is very very obvious that this
officer
should have known that they were firing
taser number one and number two
didn't know they were not firing taser
hey dante wright says that rashida talib
was met with aggression and violence
i am done with those who condone
government-funded murder no more
policing
incarceration and militarization it
can't be reformed um i'd love for all
democrats to run on this
no more policing or incarceration let's
see how that works out one of the things
that you may have noticed
is that the murder rate in minneapolis
has skyrocketed since the george floyd
protest you're gonna see another murder
skyrocket
in the aftermath of this particular
shooting because the police are simply
going to stop policing
at the behest of people like we're
shooting to leap seriously guys do it
really do it run on this run on no more
policing and no more incarceration and
see how far it takes you
there's a reason that murder in
america's major metropolitan areas was
up 33
last year by the way this should be a
pretty ringing rebuttal
of many of the claims made over the past
couple of decades about why the crime
rate declined from 1994 to 2015.
there are many theories that were put
out there ranging from lead paint was
removed from schools
to abortion to economics okay but here's
the thing
the economy was kind of booming in 2014
2015 2016 or at least it was on a growth
curve and that did not stop a massive
uptick in violence during those years as
soon as you start loosening the
restrictions with regard to criminal
behavior getting uptick in violence
if your solution to police misconduct is
disband the police
you don't have the best interest of your
constituents at heart so seriously
democrats do this
keep running on this please please we'll
get to more of this in just one second
first
let's talk about your safety and
security at home a lot is happening out
there on your front door
and that's one thing that hasn't changed
at my house i get more groceries
delivered and
friends stopping by as the pandemic
wanes it's never been more important to
be able to see who is there or what is
happening in my front door that's why
now is the perfect time to upgrade your
doorstep
with a ring and video doorbell with ring
you can see it and speak to whoever is
at the door from anywhere right on your
phone you'll never miss a visitor
whether it's your neighbor your dinner
your groceries you can keep those
packages and delivery safe
with motion detection you get notified
even if they don't ring the doorbell if
somebody stops by
or something is going on ring will let
you know i love that ring video doorbell
when we moved from california to florida
it was
literally one of the first things my
wife said was get the ring video
doorbell put it on the door
i also want ring devices around my house
so i can keep track of my kids and keep
track of my property
you can do the same right now get a
special offer on the ring welcome kit at
ring.com
it comes with that ring video doorbell 3
and the trim pro it's the perfect way to
upgrade your front door
and start your ring experience head on
over to ring.com
and that again is ring.com ring.com
go check them out right now okay so
the democratic response to this shooting
is that police apparently should either
be
disbanded or completely reformed
minnesota's governor tim walls who's a
democrat
he says we have to stop pretending we
can't do anything i don't know
honest to god i don't know what you can
do in this particular situation beyond
officers who behave like this
need to go to jail i i don't know what
systemic policing needs to be changed
maybe a better selection techniques for
people who join the cops better training
techniques
for people who join the police force but
other than that
what is the systemic is there is this a
systemic racial problem when somebody
withdraws a taser or withdraws a gun and
thinks it's a taser
is it a systemic racial problem when
there's no evidence in the derrick
chauvin case for example that race was
even a
uh driving factor in that particular
case it doesn't matter here's tim walls
pushing this
we can stop pretending that this is just
the natural order of the universe and
things happen this way
i'm going to demand that the legislature
finally hold some hearings
on some of these reforms as i said that
have passed in other states
and have proven to make a difference
things that are supported by both law
enforcement and community members
things that we know that would reduce
the chance of a routine traffic stop
escalating in to a loss of life
there are things that can be done okay
so in this particular case
the routine traffic stop should not have
turned into a loss of life because it
was in fact
an accident right as you can see from
the body cam footage
a tragic terrible accident for which the
officer again will likely spend jail
time
it is also true that in this particular
incident the situation
escalated at the beginning because the
person resisted arrest that does not
mean the punishment for resisting arrest
is getting shot in the chest obviously
so i'm i'm just i don't know what
solution walls is proposing here other
than he's just going to say things like
we know the solution to this i i don't
know this will do really do you know the
solution to cops just doing bad things
that are already criminal
i i don't i don't know the solution to
that and i don't think rashida talib
does
and i don't think that tim walls does
but here's the same paul mayer saying we
have to keep asking ourselves
why does this keep happening over and
over is melvin carter the mayor of
saint paul we have to ask ourselves
why how does this keep
happening over and over again in america
in the world
in minnesota we have to know
that the first law of motion
is that objects in motion will remain in
motion until some force stops it from
happening
and so when we recognize this strong
horrific
trend that keeps happening over and over
and over again
we have to know that dante wright will
not be the last name
will not be the last hashtag on this
list until
and unless we take decisive and urgent
action to ensure that he is okay i don't
know what that means
i honestly don't know what that means
what what exactly are you proposing here
are you proposing like russia to believe
that we get rid of the cops
are you proposing something that
magically prevents officers from making
mistakes
and what exactly are you proposing here
and the general tenor again
is that this is happening every day how
does this keep happening
that the real problem for black men in
america is that this is likely to happen
to you if you're pulled over for a
traffic stop there are literally
millions
of officer civilian interactions every
year in the united states the number of
actual cases that happen like this
are ex like just on a statistical level
are extremely rare
that's why we know their names and there
are very few things in the united states
that happen every single day to many
many many people where you know
everybody's name
this has happened to but you know
everybody's name and the reason you know
everybody's name is because
statistically speaking
it is in fact extremely rare in fact
it's significantly more rare
for the cops to shoot a black person on
arm than it is for the cops to shoot
a person who is white unarmed that's
according to roland fryer's study
done at harvard university just a couple
of years ago
as matt walsh has pointed out the the
notion that this is a
race-based situation in brooklyn center
is
a very weird take matt walsh at the
daily wire says the shooting appears to
be a tragic accident for which the
officer might be held criminally liable
it doesn't appear to be the sort of
racist execution that black lives matter
has made it out to be indeed
none of the police shootings protested
by blm have lived up to that billing
what we've learned time and again is
that the writers don't ultimately care
what happens
he says between january 1st 2020 and
march 31 2021
there have been 507 white people shot to
death by police compared to 271 black
people
right nobody knows the name of any of
the white people the only white person
anybody knows the name of is ashley
babbitt
right because she's the person who broke
into the capitol along with the other
rioters and then was shot in the neck
we didn't hear a lot of protestations
about police brutality in that case
indeed a lot of the as matt walsh points
out a lot of people had no problem at
all with ashley babbitt being shot
okay so when we say that this is a
massive trend the way that the saint
paul mayor is saying
why does this keep happening this has to
this won't stop happening until there's
major system what change are we talking
about
in fact can we be very specific about
the problem we're talking about are we
talking about the problem of policeman's
training
because there we have a solution i was
talking about the problem of police
brutality because there there's some
possible solutions
or is the implication that black people
are being routinely targeted for murder
because this case does not support that
idea
even this case as tragic and horrific as
it is does not support that actual idea
now joe biden had some words about this
particular case the word was woe
he just said that a lot so he was asked
about about
the dante right shooting and here was
joe biden's
rather adult take
[Music]
what i'm going to do i'm going to see
you all again in a few minutes
i've just took taken the time to realize
a few minutes late to listen to the
press conference
i'm preparing a statement and i'll be
happy to talk with you at the next
meeting
uh inspiring stuff there from the
president of the united states remember
that time when
it was treated as though literally joe
biden tweeted out
last year that every violent incident
was on donald trump because he was the
president of the united states did that
cease to apply because joe biden's
president now
how does that mouth work exactly in a
second we're going to get to the looting
and rioting
that inevitably seem to follow each one
of these incidents regardless of the
details
of the incident first let's talk about
your sleep quality so
the reality is that i have very small
children they wake me up at odd times
that means i really value my sleep that
means when i get on that mattress i want
to be asleep right away
and the way i know that will work is
because i have a mattress that is made
specifically for me
helix sleep has a quiz it takes just two
minutes to complete matches your body
type and sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress for you
why would you buy a mattress made for
someone else with helix you're getting a
mattress you know will be the perfect
for the way you sleep
everybody is unique helix knows that
they have several different mattress
models to choose from
they have soft medium and firm
mattresses mattresses great for cooling
you down if you sleep hot
even a helix plus mattress for plus size
folks so if you're looking for a
mattress you take the quiz you order the
mattress you're matched to the mattress
comes right to your doorstep for free
you don't ever need to go to a mattress
store again
helix is awesome but you don't need to
take my word for it helix was awarded
the number one best overall mattress
pick of 2020 by both gq
and wired magazine just go to
helixsleep.com take their two minutes
sleep quiz they will match you to a
customized mattress that will give you
the best sleep of your life they have a
10-year warranty you get to try it out
for 100 nights risk free they'll even
pick it up for you if you don't love it
but you will helix is offering up to 200
bucks off all their mattress orders
today and two free pillows for our
listeners at helixsleep.com that's helix
sleep dot com
slash ben go check them out right now
okay so rioting and looting did break
out
in minneapolis over the past couple of
nights after all of this
in fact ironically and sadly and really
pathetically some of the businesses that
were looted at this time were also
ransacked last year
during the george floyd riots this is
according to ryan mills over at national
review
several stores ransacked after sunday's
fatal police shooting in brooklyn centre
minnesota where vandalized and looted
less than a year ago
in the riots that ensued across the twin
cities after george floyd's death and
police custody
and people wonder why it is that
criminal activity and rioting and
looting
lead to people withdrawing their
businesses from major cities and the
loss of both tax revenue and jobs
that would be why when you tell the cops
to stand back
when the cops are deprived of their
ability to do their jobs
two things can be short ones cops have
to have ability to do their jobs also
cops
should be prosecuted if they pull a gun
instead of a taser and shoot somebody
right like all of this can be true at
once but what's happened in the
aftermath of all of this is this
widespread
reaction in which our nation's political
leaders say that the police themselves
are inherently bad widespread change is
necessary and also we're going to change
the terms of contract under which police
officers work
thus to make it impossible for police to
do ordinary police work not to break the
law but to do ordinary police work
the foot locker t-mobile and gamestop
stores in the city were among the
sources looted last may
said mark allen president of the
brooklyn center business association
he worries about the lasting impact the
second go round of rioting will have on
the business community
well yes according to ellen
what would be the rationale or the
reason that any of these businesses
would want to open in our community
again is frustrating
he says i can understand morning for it
i can understand protesting for it but
then on the flip side these are the same
people running out of foot locker saying
yeah i got a free pair of shoes because
of this it doesn't make any sense
okay well it's there is something
fascinating that is happening
here not not not just because you can
see the impact here right which is the
sports leagues
things were so bad that the sports
leagues canceled all their games in
minneapolis in the aftermath of this
if your city is so lawless that in the
aftermath of a bad policing incident
you have to cancel the twins game you
have to cancel the timberwolves game
you're put your city's out of control
according to the new york post the
minnesota twins postponed monday's game
against the red sox after the fatal
shooting of dante wright which has
caused widespread protests throughout
the city
wright was killed during that traffic
stop the statement said out of respect
for the tragic events that occurred
sunday in brooklyn center
and following the additional details in
this evolving situation the minnesota
twins have decided it is in the best
interest of our fans
staff players and community to not play
today's game the decision was made by
the twins after consultation with mlb
and local and state officials and the
nba
did the same thing minnesota
timberwolves did the same thing
they suspended their game last night
they put out a statement saying the nba
announced
in light of the tragic events in the
minneapolis area yesterday tonight's
game between the brooklyn nets and the
minnesota timberwolves
at the target center has been postponed
okay the reality of course is that
it's really not the shooting that is
causing the postponement it is the
looting that is causing the postponement
there are tragic shootings that happen
in major cities like minneapolis every
day
most of them the vast majority of them
do not involve the cops if chicago's
sports teams were to delay every game
based on tragic shootings in the city
they could not have a day where there
was a game in the city of chicago
and what's happening here is that
criminals are running out of control
looting and rioting in the aftermath of
incidents like this and by the way
cheered on by the media cheered on by
the media
okay so for example yesterday the police
chief in brooklyn center was talking and
he was talking about the fact that there
was in fact rioting in minneapolis
and one of the reporters insisted no
there was no rioting so we are going
all the way back to the beginning of the
summer last year
when the media insisted that even though
you were watching
buildings burn in the background of the
george floyd protests
there was no rioting at all you remember
reporters literally standing in front of
burning buildings and explaining these
were mostly peaceful protests
well here is the the brooklyn center
police chief saying no there was rioting
and a reporter saying
stop saying writing there is no rioting
who are you going to believe the
reporters or your own eyes
here's the police chief versus the
reporter here just so everybody's clear
i was
fronting front and center at the protest
at the
at the riot we not
so i was we were being the officers
that were putting themselves in harm's
way were being pelted with frozen cans
a pop they were being belted with
concrete blocks
and yes we had our helmets on and we had
other protection gear but
an officer was injured hit in the head
with a brick that was a hennepin county
deputy
he was transported to the hospital so we
had to make decisions
okay but the media are insisting no no
no everything is perfectly peaceful
everything is perfectly good so we are
back to last summer when rioting and
looting is justified
on the basis of a manslaughter case
against a police officer
that's that's where we are now the
what's what's interesting is because
trump is no longer president
democrats seem a lot less sanguine with
the rioting and eluding this time so you
remember at the very beginning
there were like the minneapolis mayor he
went down to the protesters and some of
the writers and he's like i'm with you
guys i'm with you and then they yelled
at him and they called him a racist and
all this sort of stuff
and remember that many of the top
democratic officials were rather
hesitant to talk in very strong terms
about rioting and looting
joe biden was actually somewhat
exceptional in this regard fairly early
on and it was june 2nd after the after
the riots started
he said that you know there really is no
justification for writing it was much
softer language
well now biden is is you know going
after a little bit harder
because of course joe biden is president
now and it doesn't look as wonderful for
there to be rioting and looting while
he's the president of the united states
because after all if you blame trump for
the rioting and looting guess who's
president now it ain't trump anymore
i want to make it clear again there is
absolutely no
justification none for looting
no justification for violence peaceful
protest
understandable and the fact is that you
know
we do know that the anger pain and
trauma that exists in the black
community
in that environment is real it's serious
and it's
but it will not justify violence and or
looting okay and then minnesota's
governor tim walls the same guy who was
saying we can't stand this anymore and
we know there are solutions i remind you
at this time that the democrats
filibustered tim scott's police reform
bill last year
man they used that jim crow tool the
filibuster in order to stop a black
republican senator's police reform bill
just a quick reminder how much of this
is politics here's minnesota's governor
tim wall saying there's no tolerance for
looting in the state i mean sure we let
you like run completely through
the city last year but now there's no
tolerance for looting at least
for those who choose to go out and as
mayor carter said to exploit
these tragedies for destruction or
personal gain
you can rest assured that the largest
police presidents in minnesota history
and coordination will be prepared
you will be arrested you will be charged
and there will be consequences for those
actions
it's not debatable you're not making the
case you're hurting the case
you're undermining the grief and you
hear it from families time and time
again
don't you dare step into our space where
we're trying to enact change through our
system
you know there's a little bit of a
change in attitude here from last year
i was in la last year during the riots
and all the public officials were like
well we kind of have to give them space
to riot i mean it's like not great that
they're doing this but we'll tell the
cops to stand back and stand down we'll
curfew the entire city at 6 p.m to make
sure
that people have the space to go out and
do what they want to do we'll shut down
rodeo drive at 1 pm in la
and now it's like joe biden's president
and suddenly all these democratic
policies are like you know what we can't
stand
this rioting and this this got to stop
we need some law and order around here
yes yes so much of this is political it
really is
quite astonishing and this again ties it
into the broader narrative
and the broader narrative is that with
democrats in charge finally solutions
are on the way right there's a dual
narrative the dual narrative is one
that every incident like this is proof
of systemic american racism
okay this this is not a racist incident
i i'm unaware of any racial
overtones or undertones to this
particular incident the
i've seen the body cam footage you've
seen the body cam footage
speaking of which the derrick shoven
incident they still have not shown
either first degree purposeful attempt
at murder or two i mean they didn't
charge that or two
racism in that particular case okay but
the narrative is that whenever there's a
police incident
involving a non-black police officer and
a black
and a black victim then that means
that systemic american racism is at play
and secondarily the democrats are going
to solve this thing
democrats are really going to get on
this and they're going to solve this
thing so the editorial board of the
washington post has a piece today titled
has nothing been learned from george
floyd's death
okay so first off he hasn't been
convicted yet derek chovin i noticed i
noticed that
they're still in the process of that
trial and in fact the case is not going
swimmingly for the prosecution they're a
bunch of holes in the case we've
discussed them before the defense is
beginning
to lay out its case this week by friday
the defense will have closed
and they expect a verdict basically by
monday but here's the washington post
trying to connect to all of these cases
with a thin read
right suggesting this is all about
police racism even though again the
shoving case was not a case of racism
as far as i'm aware in any piece of
evidence and this case is not about
racism as far as i'm aware
bad policing can just be bad policing in
any case the washington post is safe to
say no one likes to be pulled over by
police but for black and brown people
there is extra dread and fear and danger
i'd like to see some statistical proof
that this is the case the shocking video
of a black army officer being held at
gunpoint and pepper sprayed by police
during a traffic stop in virginia and
the fatal shooting of another black man
by police in minnesota who stopped him
because of expired tags on his car
once again spotlight problems on how
police treat people of color and the
need for fundamental changes in how
police operate now here is where you
would expect there to be
some sort of statistical evidence
demonstrating that motorists who are
black
are treated differently when pulled over
than motorists who are white
in terms of deadly force used or heavy
force used right here's where you'd
expect nope
washington post ain't gonna bring any
because anecdotal evidence is better
than statistical or data-driven evidence
by the way
i noted yesterday on this virginia case
i talked about that
and i noted that that looked like a bad
case of the police overreacting and
acting badly with regard to the person
in the car if you actually watch the
entire tape and i recommend to you that
you watch the entire tape through with
officer brandon tatum who's been a guest
on this program he did a youtube video
on which he went through in detail
that particular traffic stop the the
black army officer who was held during
that stop
the lights started flashing he drove for
another mile and a half he said he did
so because he wanted to get into a
lighted area and then he refused a bunch
of commands by the police to put his
hands
outside the car and to get out of the
car meanwhile he was simultaneously
live-streaming the thing
so does that mean that he was treated
correctly by the police
it doesn't mean he was treated correctly
by the police it also doesn't mean that
he was you know completely complying
with their commands and then they just
went hog wild on him that is not a
completely accurate take on that
particular incident either
so yesterday i had sort of given the
impression that in that particular case
the the it was a completely one-sided
case of the cops being completely awful
and the person who was
pulled over being completely innocent
wasn't quite that simple
and i said we have to wait for details
on the minnesota case well now we have
the details on the minnesota case and
that one looks awful in pretty much
every respect
and the one in virginia it looks awful
in some respects but not in other
respects namely the police officers in
that case actually de-escalated use of
force
so for example the police officer who
pepper sprayed the the
black army officer he actually had a gun
in his hand he took the gun he holstered
the gun
and then he took out the pepper spray
should have used the pepper spray on the
guy
probably not also the guy didn't obey
police commands like on a bunch of
occasions he refused to unbuckle and get
out of the car after told to do so
many many times he was live streaming
and and arguing with the officers
thoroughly and none of that means that
the police officers
acted appropriately but to treat that as
this is a vicious case of police racism
ignores some of the complicating factors
but according to the washington post
none of that matters the release of
footage showing how corona zario was
mistreated by police in windsor virginia
and the killing sunday of dante wright
in a suburb of minneapolis coincide with
the ongoing trial of the former police
officer charged with the murder of
george
george floyd a case that ostensibly
prompted a national reckoning on racial
inequities in policing has nothing been
learned from that tragedy again there
are drawing lines
from dots and it doesn't matter that the
dots are different
in kind in each case again there's the
implication of racism in the shoving
case
is not there the implication of racism
in the virginia case is
it's being imputed by the media but is
there evidence to suggest that if a
white guy
in a car refused over and over to obey
police commands that it would have ended
the same way
because again there's no evidence of the
police officers actually being racist in
that particular case
in this particular case is there
evidence of systemic police racism but
that's the entire premise here
and the entire premise is supported by a
handful of anecdotes where you didn't
even make the case
right those are the questions that come
to mind watching how police interacted
with lieutenant rosario
in the december 5th 2020 incident that
is now the subject of a federal lawsuit
even though the servicemen dressed in
his army uniform had committed no crime
was respectful had his arms up and was
clearly confused about why he'd been
stopped the officers treated him with
contempt and belligerence
that's a mischaracterization of what
actually happened okay he
they they say that he was respectful and
he had his arms up he actually did not
obey police commands
like over and over and over again watch
the entire tape
that does not mean that the police were
correct but that's a mischaracterization
of what led up
to that entire incident more information
is needed an investigation is underway
says the washington post into the death
of mr wright a 20-year-old shot after a
routine traffic stop went tragically
awry
brooklyn center minneapolis police chief
tim gannon said the officer meant to
fire a taser but made an accidental
discharge from her gun
during a news conference monday the
chief played an unedited clip of police
body camera video showing the officer
yelling taser taser taser firing a gun
instead and then
exclaiming holy bleep i just shot him
such a mix-up seems incomprehensible
and raises obvious questions about
training well it does raise questions
about training
as far as incomprehensible is the idea
here that she was lying
that she knew she was going to shoot him
with a gun and she said taser taser
taser to what throw off the cameras or
something
police said they had stopped right
because he had expired registration tags
they discovered he had an outstanding
arrest for a misdemeanor offense and say
he resisted police well they didn't just
say he resisted police he did resist
police
they tried to break free of the cops and
he jumped back in the car he seems to
have posed no immediate danger
and he surely could have been found
another time if serving the arrest
warrant
was so vital okay well now you're
getting into the area where the where
the
washington post is just engaging in
conjecture if an outstanding warrant for
a guy he tries to resist arrest by
jumping back in his car and the idea is
okay so we just let him go
how yeah and then what would have
happened if you'd taken that car and hit
somebody
then the implication is the cop should
have arrested him right
hindsight is is 20 20 in in a lot of
these cases again especially when
there's an intervening
situation in which an officer violates
the law and violates basic training
protocol
but says the washington post part of the
way the police have traditionally been
trained is to think they have to win at
any cost but that cost is far too high
no that's
saying that the officer in this case was
acting as an outgrowth of a generalized
police belief that you have to win at
any cost
ignores the fact that the police officer
in this case acknowledges
that she did something wrong in the
immediate aftermath of the incident
and so again the media wished to draw a
narrative and then they wish to use that
narrative to foment a lot of the looting
and
and the violence in fact there was this
amazing video yesterday on cnn
of a black man approaching members of
cnn
saying to them guys would you just leave
you're making things worse
the answer there is yeah that's correct
they are making things worse no question
because they don't analyze the situation
they don't analyze the context of every
situation they don't analyze the fact
pattern
it's just not important to them at all
here's that clip
now you can see now you can see y'all be
twisting up the story you want to talk
to me
do you want to talk to me okay cool
don't take my mic but we're cool okay
all right so tell me what you think
about what's going on i think about this
is all the press and all the extra which
i do
makes this worse you think so yes y'all
need to get up out of here
with all that twisting up the media all
righty in just one second we're gonna
get to the
federal government absolutely blowing it
with regard to its messaging on the
vaccine
first let us talk about the fact that
when it comes to investing
investing in art is a really interesting
investment right because
you know the fact is that you really
can't afford to buy a renoir painting
for example but it is a great investment
if you
were able to that thing would just churn
out
investment value over time well
investing in art should not be reserved
for people who can afford like the
entire renoir instead did you know that
only one percent of day traders actually
turn a profit
why are many of us mistaking picking
stocks for serious investing you can't
control the markets you can control your
risks
how do billionaires of the likes of bill
gates and jeff bezos control risk they
invest in blue chip art and you can do
it
too contemporary art prices outperform
the s p 500 by 172
from 1995 to 2020 with the fed injecting
money into the economy like never before
smart investors are moving some of their
wealth to hard assets like art and
hedging against inflation
you can get involved too masterworks dot
io it's a private platform that lets you
invest in paintings by artists like
basquat and monet
at a fraction of the cost it's no wonder
that 84
of the ultra wealthy collector an
exclusive asset class that has
historically been held
by the top one percent alone but it
doesn't need to be that way
you can basically fractionally buy into
a great piece of art and hold the value
of that art to start investing in art
visit masterworks dot io today skip the
ten thousand person waitlist just tell
them
that i sent you see important
information at masterworks dot io
slash disclaimer again that is
masterworks dot io
get started today investing in a really
creative fascinating
and uh and value-laden way that's
masterworks dot io alrighty in just a
second we're going to get to the federal
government completely blowing
its messaging on on vaccinations it's
one of the worst public health messaging
disasters i've seen in my lifetime we'll
get to that in a second first
it's already episode five and people
cannot get enough of candace owens or
her new show candace
if you haven't checked it out yet i
don't know what you're waiting for
candace is a thought leader she hosts a
lively series of guests every week for
discussion panel interviews
and my favorite portion her cancel
corner this week she's hosting comedian
and podcaster adam carolla
tune in you're not going to want to miss
their conversation the show streams on
fridays 9 p.m eastern 8 p.m central
at dailywire.com but you can get the
audio podcast kansas on apple
spotify or wherever you listen to your
podcast so if you need some candace
owens in your podcast feed look no
further head on over to apple podcast or
spotify
subscribe today and be sure to leave a
five star review if you like
while you hear you're listening to the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
meanwhile the federal government is
blowing it again it is amazing we spent
like a year
talking about how donald trump is the
establishment media your establishment
media donald trump was screwing with the
public health messaging him with all his
bleach and all of his
and all his talk about masks and how
he's screwing it up and the only forces
saving america where the cdc and the fda
i would just like to point something out
here i cannot name a thing i think that
cdc and the fda did right
during this entire pandemic the cdc blew
it on masking at the very beginning the
fda blew it on testing
at the very beginning the fda then
proceeded to hold up
the testing on the vaccines costing us
precious weeks of time
in which people were getting covered at
extraordinary rates and now the fda is
making a move
that is beyond the cdc has been
politicized thoroughly got richelle
wolenski out there saying we should open
the schools and then the minute that joe
biden says he doesn't want the schools
open she reverses herself
and she says the schools really
shouldn't be open meanwhile you've got
people
like anthony fauci out there suggesting
routinely that vaccines are overrated
like what is it seriously what has our
nation's federal public health
infrastructure actually done that is
good
can you name it i i'm like throughout
the pandemic can you name those things
because i'm waiting to hear
examples of it the latest example of the
federal government
absolutely blowing it in an
extraordinary way is that
the u.s the fda and the cdc have now
said they're going to stop using the
johnson and johnson vaccine
and now why in the world would they do
this we have millions of those doses
going out in fact we have something like
6.8 million americans 7 million
americans
who have taken doses of the johnson and
johnson vaccine
it is a very effective vaccine it is a
one-shot vaccine it is not a two-shot
vaccine
which means that you can trash it out
really really quickly it's about 80
percent effective as opposed to like the
90 95 percent that you get from pfizer
or moderna so why exactly are they
stopping the johnson and johnson shots
i kid you not here's the new york times
reporting federal health agencies on
tuesday called for an immediate pause
in use of johnson johnson's single dose
covered vaccine after six
recipients in the united states
developed a rare disorder involving
blood clots within about two weeks of
vaccination
all six recipients were women between
the ages of 18 and 48 one woman died a
second woman in nebraska has been
hospitalized
in critical condition nearly 7 million
people in the united states have
received
johnson and johnson shots so far so we
are shutting down the distribution
of vaccine that has now been put in the
arms of seven million people
because six people got a condition
six so that means that
basically your chances of ending up with
this blood clot
if indeed the vaccine causes the blood
clot because we don't know yet it could
be a complicating factor
if the vaccine causes the blood clot in
some rare way
how rare is this well the chance of
being struck by lightning in the united
states about one in five hundred
thousand
so this would be about the chance of
being struck by lightning two times
right or at least the chance of being
struck by lightning
but like it's half that chance
so i i don't even know what the
statistical equivalent of that is
this is insane i mean crazy towns
the the notion that you are shutting
down the distribution of the johnson
johnson vaccine because your chances are
one in over a million
of getting a blood clot you want to talk
about creating a bubble society and by
the way there are downside risks here if
you don't get the vaccine you're
significantly more likely to diet covet
particularly if you're in a vulnerable
group
if you're an obese lady who's 35 and you
don't get the vaccine what do you think
is more likely you're going to die of
the blood clot or you're going to die at
covid
this is insane but the federal
government is doing this
because they are ridiculous because our
public health messaging on these
vaccines has been
absolute horse crap absolute garbage
according to the new york times we are
recommending a pause in the use of this
vaccine out of an abundance of caution
your abundance of caution is not
cautious
it's reckless it is reckless to tell
millions they're nine million doses
waiting to go out
right now it is reckless to tell people
they should not get the vaccine because
of a one in one million chance they
might get a blood clot
but the fda dr peter marks says right
now these adverse events appear to be
extremely rare but we're
pausing out of an abundance of caution
that is not cautious covid is running
rampant in michigan right now
in fact christine whitmer has been
begging for there to be
more code vaccine from johnson johnson
in her state
and you're telling we're going to hold
this up because you know
you might get struck by an alien landing
craft or something
you never know well the move was framed
as a recommendation to health
practitioners in the states
the federal government is expected to
pause administration of the vaccine at
all federally run vaccination sites
federal officials expect that state
health officials will take this as a
strong signal to do the same
scientists with the fda and cdc will
jointly examine possible links between
the vaccine and the disorder and
determine whether the fda should
continue to authorize use of the vaccine
for all adults or limit the
authorization again the fda and the cdc
have been awful throughout this pandemic
this is something that i know we've been
ignoring because we're supposed to
pretend the federal government is good
at this they suck
okay the federal government has been
garbage at this if the fda had
accelerated trials on these coveted
vaccines
little known fact do you know when the
coding was done
for the mrna vaccine that was a bridge
that was eventually used to kill covet
do you know when that was coded january
of 2020
january okay before people even knew
that this thing was going to be a global
pandemic in the united states
there was already coding for the mrna
vaccine it then took
nine ten months to develop this thing
and run it through all the fda trials
if they'd accelerated it by even three
weeks how many lives have been saved but
the fda is here to save you guys the fda
is what you do
it's ridiculous the cdc and the fda have
been a garbage show
all throughout this but you're supposed
to trust your government doctors
they know all it's unclear whether the
pause and the use of the johnson johnson
vaccine will upset the biden
administration's plans to deliver enough
vaccine
to be able to inoculate all adults in
the united states by the end of may says
the new york times
or whether the demand will be made up by
other manufacturers
this is absurd at the highest level
everybody with any brain
understands how absurd this is in
washington dc they canceled every
johnson johnson vaccine appointment from
april 13th to 17th
great idea guys it's going great the fda
put out a series of tweets they said
as of 4 12 april 12 6.8 million plus
doses of the johnson johnson vaccine
have been administered
the cdc and fda are reviewing data
involving six reported cases
treatment of this specific type of blood
clot is different from the treatment
that might be typically
administered cbc will convene a meeting
of the advisory committee on
immunization practices on wednesday
to further review these cases and assess
their potential significance you know
you might have wanted to
i don't know call that meeting before
you announced a complete shutdown
on the vaccine that is going out to
millions of americans right now
but this is all part and parcel of the
insane over
zealousness and ridiculous caution that
is actually reckless
by our public health officials i mean
anthony fauci said yesterday that after
you're vaccinated you still
should not go and eat and drink indoors
screw off dude there is no data to
suggest this
none okay anthony fauci is just saying
he's just pulling this stuff directly
out of his colon
it's it's amazing that this person is a
well-respected public figure
eating and drinking indoors in
restaurants and bars
is that okay now
no it's still not okay for the simple
reason that the level of infection the
dynamics of infection
in the community are still really
disturbingly high
and if you are vaccinated please
remember
that you still have to be careful and
not get involved in
crowded situations particularly indoors
where people are not wearing masks
this is just horse crap once you are
vaccinated your chances of passing this
thing on to another person
are so low that the cdc itself has said
that you if
you're in a room with another person who
has coveted and you don't end up
symptomatic you don't have to quarantine
what the hell are you talking about
these vaccines are so effective
that they prevent virtually all serious
disease and death
and yet you're saying that i can't go to
a restaurant no one's listening to this
crap anymore
and when you downplay the effect of the
vaccine you end up with people being
like so what the hell is the point of me
taking this thing
we don't have any longitudinal testing
on it so why exactly when i take a
vaccine where it doesn't even solve any
problems in my life
but anthony fauci again this abundance
of caution approach
began with we're going to shut down all
industry in the united states for a year
and just blow out the government dollar
which in fact is not caution it's
recklessness then it turned into
we're going to shut down the vaccine
distribution out of caution which is
recklessness because people need the
vaccine
now it's you can't go back to
restaurants and you know revive american
industry
out of abundance of caution it's not
caution there's a point
where your caution becomes recklessness
there's a point where your definition of
caution
becomes such reckless insanity that
you're destroying people's lives and
putting them at further health risk
that is where we are right now when
anthony fauci says we can't be declaring
victory prematurely
you know what the danger is right now
that you're going to declare loss
forever that is the danger the danger is
when you tell people they have to stay
in their house no matter what you're
destroying american society you're
destroying the economy and
by the way when it comes to things like
this vaccine you're actually destroying
people's ability
to get the vaccine they need and yet
people still trust our public health
officials
amazing amazing stuff you know what got
us out of this pandemic private
pharmaceutical companies big pharma and
the states that's what got us out of
this pandemic not the feds
not the fda not the cdc alrighty we'll
be back here later today with an
additional hour of content
coming up soon is matt wall show it airs
at 1 30 pm eastern be sure to check it
out over at dailywire.com i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover and our assistant director is
pavo wiedowski
editing is by adam sciavitz audio is
mixed by mike coromina
hair and makeup is by fabiola christina
production assistant is jessica kranz
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021
on the matte wall show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you
your family our country not just
politics but culture faith
current events all the fundamentals if
they matter to you come check out the
show